-Our next guest
is an award-winning
investigative journalist
and staff writer
for "The New Yorker."
Please welcome to the show
Jane Mayer, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Jane, thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you.
Good to be with you.
-You are an
investigative journalist.
You cover dark money.
You cover corruption
in politics.
Do people panic when they
get a phone call from you?
-I have read
that people have said
that when they hear
a message from me,
they call their solicitor
and get their,
you know, affairs in order.
It's not the most flattering
thing to read about yourself,
but I have read that.
-But then what do you do?
So I would assume
a lot of people
initially don't want
to talk to you.
I would assume you don't
give up at that point.
Who do you reach out to next
when the sort of, I don't know,
subject of a story won't talk?
-Yeah, so rule one
is never give up, okay?
And what do you do?
You have to report
around them sometime.
And, you know,
you get desperate.
Some of the times -- One of
the things that's worked for me
is I found a lot
of great information
from calling people's families.
-Oh, yeah.
-Especially people's mothers.
[ Laughter ]
-If I wouldn't talk to you
but then I heard
you were calling my mother,
I would immediately
call you back.
-It usually works like that.
But sometimes
you can get to the mother
before the person
calls you back,
and then you get just, like,
a mother lode.
-Yeah, there you go.
That's how they originally
came up with the name.
-It must be, yeah.
-So you've reported a lot about
the fight for abortion rights.
You have a big piece coming up.
Obviously I think a lot of
people maybe weren't expecting
the Kansas voters to reject
this rollback of reproductive
rights last night.
Were you surprised, and what
do you see moving forward?
-Well, so I've been watching it
really closely.
I actually have been talking
to Democratic operatives,
including James Carville,
who said a few weeks ago,
"This is the one.
You got to watch it.
Because if the pro-choice people
win in Kansas,
it's just gonna rock the
Republicans back on their heels
and it's gonna
energize the Democrats."
And he wasn't entirely sure
what was going to happen,
but he said
he felt good about it.
So I had a little bit
of advance notice on the thing.
It is amazing because Kansas
is obviously a very red state.
I mean, and I think --
I mean, to me, what it means
is we're sort of getting --
we're in the consequences phase
of politics
where you're beginning
to see the consequences
of right-wing rule
that's more extreme
than most people in the country.
-Well, it was
a surprising result,
but it wasn't surprising in that
all the polling you ever see
shows that most people
wanted Roe to stand.
-Well, this is true.
But it's just -- I mean, and
that's so -- it's a great point.
Because most of these states, if
you look at the general public,
they support things like access
to abortion within reason,
you know, legal abortion.
And they support
restrictions on guns.
They actually support
higher taxes on the super rich.
I mean, all these things
that never get passed.
But what's interesting
is the state legislatures
are far more extreme
than the people themselves.
-You have written a lot
about dark money in politics,
corruption in politics,
and recently have been
doing some writing
about the Supreme Court.
And obviously the Supreme Court
as an idea is held, you know,
with this very great esteem
and yet not immune to dark money
and influence
from outside forces.
Do you think people
are surprised
when they read pieces of yours
insofar as they didn't think
that this was possible
of happening
to the Supreme Court?
-I think so.
I mean, I think all of us
grew up revering it
and thinking
it's above politics.
But if you look at polls now,
it's at a low ebb
for popular trust
in the Supreme Court,
and I think it's because people
are beginning to see it
as so political
and taking such extreme stances.
I think it's that,
and then you're right.
There is money
that people don't realize
is going into confirming
these justices.
Millions of dollars have gone
into dark money groups
that have pushed for these
very far right justices.
And most of us reporters,
including myself,
still don't know where
those millions are coming from.
It's almost impossible
to figure out.
But I'm going to try.
-So you --
Well, we're glad you're trying.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You wrote a -- You wrote
a fascinating piece
about Clarence Thomas's wife,
Ginni Thomas,
and went out of your way,
which I think everyone does,
saying, like, "Look, obviously,
you know, everyone's spouse
has a right to, you know,
have their own pursuits.
And you don't judge one
for the other."
With that said,
she is very deep in advocacy
and she is deep in issues
and organizations
that are bringing cases
in front of the Supreme Court,
funding -- what are they called?
Amicus?
-Amicus briefs.
-Right.
-And sort of
friend of the court briefs
that are supporting
their position, and --
and yet Clarence Thomas is not
recusing himself in these cases.
Doesn't seem like he has
any intention of doing that.
Where does this all end?
Is it basically that the
Supreme Court is just allowed
to police themselves in a way
that other judges aren't
at lower levels?
-Well, that's the thing
that's sort of amazing.
It's the highest court
in the country,
and it has
the lowest ethics bar.
It just polices itself.
The rest of the judges
in the country
are bound by a judicial code,
but they decided that
the Supreme Court is the highest
and nobody
can tell them what to do.
So they self-police.
I mean, any other judge
would have recused themselves
if they were faced
with the situation
that Clarence Thomas was.
There's actually a law
about recusal
which says that every judge,
including justices
on the Supreme Court,
are supposed to recuse
from any case
in which a spouse has a material
interest in the outcome.
We're waiting to see Ginni's
whole role in this,
but it certainly seems that she
was up to her eyeballs in it
and would be very uncomfortable
for Clarence Thomas
to be impartial
in a case like that.
-And I think we've all --
Certainly with
the super majority, right,
we're getting used to 6-3 cases
in the same way
we got used to 5-4 cases.
But there was actually
an 8-1 case
where Clarence Thomas was the
only justice to, you know --
that stood alone.
And this was the one --
If there was any one to recuse
himself, from this one,
because this was turning over
text messages from January 6th,
and we obviously know
that Ginni Thomas
was texting with Mark Meadows
at the time.
-She was,
and the texts are doozies,
if anyone's had a chance
to see them.
-To use the legal term,
they are doozies.
-So, yeah, it's an incredibly --
It's not just
a sticky situation.
It's really a serious situation,
because if you,
the American public,
lose faith in the Supreme Court
in a country where the rule
of law is everything,
things can really
deteriorate fast.
We need to revere
the Supreme Court
and we need to have transparency
so that we know
who's taking money
and who's got conflicts
of interest up there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The other thing
that's fascinating to me
is, you know, justices
like Clarence Thomas now,
it seems like
when they give speeches,
they blame the rest of us for
politicizing the Supreme Court.
And this was even before, you
know, we knew the full thrust
of Ginni's involvement
in January 6th.
Do you find -- Is that level
of hypocrisy stunning to you,
or is it what you've
come to expect?
-Well, I think sometimes
it's almost like projection.
You hear from these people
an accusation
that the press is politicizing
the Supreme Court,
and, you know, it makes you want
to take a second look
'cause it's clear it's a little
closer to home in his case.
The politics is intense in his
breakfast table, I would think.
-Yeah, you -- Another thing
that I would imagine
makes you take a closer look
at things
is names of a lot
of these organizations
are, like, the Honest Elections
Project or FreedomWorks.
When they seem to have, like,
those sort of mundane names,
is that when you're like,
"Oh, there's some real
dirty business here?"
-[ Laughs ]
It's true.
Like, the more virtuous
the title,
the more sort of mucky stuff
is usually going on
under the surface.
But it's helpful,
'cause it's like a red flag.
It's like, "Oh, I better take
a second look at this one."
-Now, is it true that before you
were investigative journalist,
your dream job
at "The New Yorker"
at a time
was to be a cartoonist?
-It actually was.
That's what I really
wanted to be.
And the first thing
I ever submitted
to "The New Yorker"
was a cartoon.
-And did you hear back?
-I did.
I got sort of a polite form note
saying, "Thanks, try again."
[ Laughter ]
-Did you feel like you had
a skill with a pen?
Were you a good artist?
-I loved cartooning.
-I did it all through college,
yeah, and it was a lot of fun.
-You weren't just, like,
jumping into it.
You had some background in it.
-Yeah.
I just couldn't figure out
how you make a living at it.
And the thing that happens
at "The New Yorker"
is they pay you by the word.
-Yeah.
Oh, so it's way better to do
long investigative journalism
than, like,
some real pithy caption.
-The more complicated,
the better.
-So I want to ask --
end by asking,
obviously investigative
journalists
are portrayed in television
and film a great deal,
oftentimes makes it
look thrilling,
like a thrilling job
that you have.
How accurate would you say
those portrayals are?
-Wishful thinking.
You know, sometimes you feel
like you're from that movie
"A Beautiful Mind."
You know, I have a whiteboard
with all these things
scribbled on it.
And if anyone walked in,
they'd bring in, like, you know,
one of those butterfly nets
to take you away, I think.
It's har-- It's --
But it truly is exciting
when you get a breakthrough,
and you do get them,
and it's like --
they are real Eureka moments,
and it's kind of incredible.
-Goose bumps?
When you realize
you have a breakthrough,
are you like, "Oh, my God"?
-No, you're like, "Thank you!"
-Well, we're the beneficiaries
of your breakthroughs, as well.
Thank you so much
for being here.
Looking forward
to your next article.
Jane Mayer, everybody!